bonjour les titres de ce journal d'abord
d'évaluation réactions et commentaires
auraient ajustements monétaires du
week-end et surtout ce qui va changer
dans la politique économique du
gouvernement monsieur jacques delors
ministre de l'économie des finances doit
venir avec nous pour en parler nous
l'attendons d'une minute à l'autre
monsieur de l'or qui vient d'annoncer le
blocage des prix des services et celui
de certains produits alimentaires il va
pouvoir nous dire pourquoi
nucléaire débat prévu pour durer deux
jours et qui risque d'être animée
plusieurs manifestations au cours du
week end ont une assez violente il hier
soir à golfech dans le tarn-et-garonne
gymnastique elle a 12 ans elle s'appelle
corinne ragazzacci elle a ébloui jugé
public aux championnats de france de
nantes enfin l'invité maître maurice
rheims académicien français surtout le
commissaire priseur le plus célèbre de
france son portrait par gérard méric au
maître maurice rheims mais il préfère je
crois qu'on l'appelle maurice rheims un
peu de familiarité ne le dérange pas 71
ans il est sans doute l'homme qui a fait
connaître au grand public une profession
mal connue celle de commissaire priseur
la télévision en l'occurrence il ya
d'ailleurs beaucoup aidé et il est sans
doute vous l'avez dit bernard pour le
public français le commissaire priseur
on peut également dire de maurice rheims
qu'il est monsieur à peu près 300 mille
coups de marteau et qu'en plus de 35 ans
de carrière il a participé de près à
tous les grands évènements français et
mondiaux dans le domaine de l'art membre
de l'académie française il a troqué le
marteau pour l'épée il est aussi
l'auteur d'une quinzaine de livres
l'évaluation de l'héritage de pablo
picasso était l'une de vos dernières
tâches importantes héritage évalué par
vous même à 120 milliards de centimes
c'est une consécration quand on est
commissaire priseur mais bon je suis
plus commissaire priseur pris longtemps
le fonds social sur une petite île
grecque il dans ce métier
je crois que cela profession de
commissaire priseur n'a rien à voir si
vous voulez que avec le fait que
j'estimais que j'ai été appelé à estimer
la cité lui ce que pouvait représenter
la succession picasso c'est un épisode
d'une vie consacrée aux objets et aux
hommes qui aiment les objets pas
n'importe quel
n'importe quel nom pour n'importe quel
objet mort facile ce qu'est la vie d'un
homme c'est la vie d'un homme si celle
de picasso son heure ce sont le voir
chez ca son atelier qu'il a laissé les
tableaux qu'il a collectionné lui-même
et c'est ça que j'étais appelé un que
j'étais appelé arrivant vous est assorti
d'un gros livre ses patients si on peut
le voir si une caméra qui peut le
montrer on en parlera tout à l'heure ça
s'appelle les collectionneurs ça ce qui
d'ailleurs très rapidement enfin très
rapidement je dire fait c'est
passionnant et on reste pas à traîner en
route on a parlé tout à l'heure mais
bien sûr vous savez que la règle du jeu
c'est vous pouvez intervenir dans
l'actualité à tout moment d'ailleurs
voici monsieur jacques delors et
voudrait probablement des choses
allaient demander merci monsieur de
l'ordre venues nous passons donc tout de
suite au sujet du jour puisque monsieur
de l'heure et là c'est la dévaluation je
rappelle les chiffres - 3 % pour le
francs +5 et demi pour cent pour le marc
la décision a été prise hier par les
ministres des finances réunis à
bruxelles et puis cette mesure que nous
venons d'apprendre monsieur de l'or et
que pierre-marie thiaville va commenter
tout de suite c'est le retour au blocage
des prix du moins partiellement mais
alors avant de revenir au pourquoi de
cette mesure faut rappeler tout de même
à quoi cela sert en deux mots cette
dévaluation de fait ce réajustement
l'intérieur du système monétaire
européen à quoi ça sert d'abord à donner
un coup d'arrêt à la spéculation contre
le franc et à l'hémorragie de devises
halak a été contrainte la banque de
france pour le soutenir quelques 50
milliards en quelques mois je crois
deuxièmement l'exportation alors ça
c'est sans doute l'effet de plus
intéressant parce qu'il donne une chance
réelle à la relance si froid moins chers
les produits proposés par nos
exportateurs à l'étranger et notamment
en allemagne le sont aussi pour faire
court disons que la r5 sera moins chère
à francfort et que la golf sera un peu
plus cher à paris cela dit les monnaies
comme les médaillons un revers et l'
avantage à l'exportation dont viennent
parler peut être contrebalancé par des
importations plus chères notamment avec
l'allemagne qui est non seulement le
premier client nous aussi nos premiers
fournisseurs alors on espère que cela
n'aura pas trop d'influx ans si le
volume de nos importations restent
modérées mais nous risquons tout de même
de cette façon d'apporter un peu
d'inflation est clair que le véritable
danger il est là au niveau de
l'inflation et de la hausse des prix
parce que la cause profonde de
l'éloignement du marc hé du franc qui
nous a contraints à cette dévaluation de
fait cette cause profonde c'est que
l'accélération de la hausse des prix en
allemagne malgré malgré son accélération
ces derniers temps est tout de même deux
moindre qu'en france cela veut dire que
si la france veut profiter des effets de
cette dévaluation il faut en même temps
un coup de frein considérable à la
hausse des prix faute de quoi on serait
peut-être monsieur de leurs obligés de
redévelopper dans trois mois ou dans six
mois là je me tourne vers vous parce que
pour pour éviter sa faute de quoi pour
éviter cela vous avez vous n'avez pas
tarder vous n'avez pas traîné en route
dès ce matin vous a lancé le blocage des
cd les prix des services et d'une
certaine d'un certain nombre de prix de
produits notamment alimentaires est ce
que ça veut dire que c'est un virage
complet de toute la politique économique
du gouvernement est ce que c'est fini la
liberté les prix si vous permettez tout
d'abord compte tenu de ce que vous avez
dit trois précisions
premièrement s'il a fallu depuis février
des pensées des devises pour soutenir le
franc je voudrais rappeler que les
quatre cinquièmes ont été dépensés avant
que le 21 mai je ne conseille au premier
ministre qui venait juste d'arriver de
prendre des mesures de réglementation
des changes et de hausses des taux
d'intérêts pour élever notre garde et
lutter contre la spéculation
deuxièmement
chaque phase nouvelle de l'histoire de
notre société et de notre économie est
marquée par
un mouvement monétaire
en 1936 le franc a été dévalué de 25% en
1958 d'un peu plus de 17% et en 1969 au
début du septennat de monsieur pompidou
de un peu plus de 12% aucune comparaison
ne peut être fait aujourd'hui puisque
nous sommes dans un système monétaire
européen
mais la différence n'est quand même que
de huit et demi pour cent à dire côté
que la première fois que qu'il ya une
concertation au niveau des ministres des
finances avant de prendre une décision
de réajustement nord depuis que le
système était européen existe cela
s'était fait dans avec d'autres pays
mais ensuite ça va mais je veux dire
c'est la première fois que la france y y
participent et cette opération je
l'avais en tête dès que j'ai été nommé
ministre d'économie des finances parce
que j'avais consulté les grands
indicateurs de économique et les grands
paramètres politiques et enfin
troisièmement puisque suffisait moi
cette parenthèse politique
mais puisque certains membres de l'ex
majorité devenu l'opposition disent
qu'ils portent le deuil
je devrais leur rappeler quand même que
pendant le septennat monsieur giscard
d'estaing et avant l'opération actuelle
le franc s'est déprécié de 30% par
rapport au 2 chemin or si l'on a porté
le deuil c'est hélas le deuil de leur
propre gestion et non pas de la nôtre et
quand je suis arrivé il y avait encore à
faire pour apurer le passé et mettre les
pendules à l'heure ces dix pour en
revenir à la dévaluation proprement dit
et on mesure que vous prenez des dès ce
matin monsieur le ministre est ce que
vraiment ce blocage des prix des
services et de certains produits
alimentaires je peux énumérer le sucre
le café la margarine le beurre le lait
etc qu'est ce que ce n'est pas en
contradiction avec ce que vous aviez
annoncé il ya jusqu'à il ya quelques
semaines c'est à dire que la liberté les
p&t matinée n'ont absolument pas la loi
ça reste la liberté
le moyen une concurrence renforcée et
vous savez tous les efforts que j'ai
fait depuis quatre mois pour qu'il en
soit ainsi et lorsque la concurrence ne
joue pas très bien d'abord la
concertation ce sont ces principes
demeurent mais vous avouerez qu'on ne
fait pas une opération monétaire tous
les jours alors qu'est ce que j'ai
constaté j'ai observé que du côté des
services qui avaient été les libérer par
mon prédécesseur
on en a profité pour faire des
augmentations qu'on est un peu au large
pour citer des exemples là où les
augmentations individuelles il y a eu la
coiffure l'entretien et la réparation
automobile par exemple et bien d'autres
donc je ne l'aimé pas au piquet cela ça
ça sera le dirige je leur demande un
effort
nous bloquons les prix des services qui
représente environ 30% de l' indice des
prix pendant
six mois mais au bout de trois mois par
des accords
concerter avec mon administration ils
peuvent sortir du blocage et donc
revenir à une liberté concertée dans des
secteurs où vous la boue et la
concurrence juin joue moins qu'entre
renault volkswagen peugeot ou british
l'élan dans les services vous intégrer
aussi le logement est ce qu'il ya un
blocage des loyers elle écoute et une
dévaluation une dévaluation du francs
une opération monétaire ça ne se
concerte pas avec tous les ministres
j'essaie vendredi soir à 8h30 que j'ai
pris monsieur sur joe frais à old mon
collègue britannique président du
conseil des ministres dans son cottage
et tu ai téléphoné pour dire voilà pour
les allemands et les français le moment
est venu de réunir un conseil
exceptionnel
donc j'ai pas pu me concerter avec tout
le monde je vais voir monsieur quillot
le ministre du logement pour ce qui est
du logement vous offrez vos râblât
blocage des loyers en ce moment comment
vous est favorable à un blocage des
loyers au moins pour les périodes on
sait si on suit je m'aperçois que sur la
période récente il y a eu des excès et
qu'il n'y a pas de contrepartie à ces
excès je serai bien obligé de faire je
vois que vous bloquez aussi pendant
trois mois les marges des importateurs
ou la santé est-ce que ce sont des gens
qui ont exagéré ou si on vous et c'est
au nom de la solidarité qui est quand
même un autre pourquoi voulez vous que
ceux qui vont bénéficier
d'une de cette mesure puisse augmenter
leurs revenus au moment où tout le monde
fait un effort donc leurs marges en
valeur absolue et maintenu leurs revenus
aussi mais n'y avait aucune raison
qu'une opération monétaire qui leur est
extérieur les amène à gagner davantage
en termes de revenus voilà ce n'est plus
de la liberté surveillée c'est du
blocage surveiller c'est un changement
de politique non parce que encore une
fois une opération monétaire ça ne se
fait pas tout le temps et il fallait
vous avez dit vous même ce matin
l'opération monétaire c'est bon pour les
exportations
vous auriez pu ajouter c'est bon pour la
reconquête du marché intérieur aurait pu
ajouter c'est bon pour la baisse du taux
du crédit en france et vous avez dit
mais est-ce que ça va pas avoir des
répercussions chez nous
ces répercussions elles peuvent être de
deux ordres elles peuvent être à travers
les produits importés c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que les marges demeurent ce
qu'elles sont il n'y a pas de diminution
du revenu des importateurs et les
d'autres précautions c'était d'éviter
que le dollar monte trop or aujourd'hui
d'après les premiers chiffres le dollar
n'a monté en francs français que de 2,40
% et la france si on excepte en italique
et un régime spécial est en tête du
système monétaire européen alors voilà
le véritable souci je vous propose qu'on
aille plus avant avec un mari qui avait
tout à l'heure sur l'ensemble de ces
mesures que vous appréciez peut-être
apprendre des réactions qu'ont suscité
les les annonces de la dévaluation
maintenant je devrais con qu'on passe la
parole à michel meyer qui est à bonn qui
va nous donner les réactions en
allemagne michel lallement fédéral a
donc accepté ce réajustement monétaire
après avoir soutenu durant plusieurs
mois le franc sur les marchés monétaires
internationaux
à cela une explication
l'intérêt bien compris de l'allemagne
tout simplement en effet la france est
le premier client est le premier
fournisseur de l'allemagne fédérale et
bonne n'a absolument aucun intérêt à ce
qu'il y ait affaiblissement dans la
france dans une situation mondiale que
l'on juge au moins sur le plan
économique très dangereuse en effet les
allemands veulent préserver à tout prix
le système monétaire européen qui permet
aux européens aux monnaies européennes
de naviguer de façon assez stable et
cela indépendamment des turbulences
provoquées par le dollar cela dit les
allemands ne s'expose pas à des risques
norme dans cette affaire dans la mesure
où je crois que le fait de penser que
une réévaluation du deutschemark
provoque une baisse de la compétitivité
de l'économie allemande est un mythe de
même que l'idée qui consiste à croire
également que partant d'une dévaluation
les produits français perd seront mieux
le marché allemand en définitive j'ai
fait une petite enquête ce matin aucune
firme française ne me semble pas avoir
encore à l'heure actuelle répercuter la
dévaluation du franc sur leurs prix en
deutschemark et on peut penser que ce
n'est pas une méthode pour mieux percer
le marché allemand
commentaire de leurs
rêves sur le monde oui tout d'abord si
les allemands ont joué le jeu du système
monétaire européen certes derniers mois
je voudrais dire que nous sommes surtout
soutenue nous mêmes et si d'autre part
en ce qui concerne nos exportateurs ils
ont besoin de réfléchir mais enfin
j'espère qu'ils en profiteront puis je
vous donne l exemple de la régie renault
quand même un exemple intéressant
puisqu'une entreprise très productive sa
productivité augmente de cet ennemi %
d'un physique par an eh bien ces
derniers mois quand renault vendaient
une voiture en allemagne elles perdent
et un ennemi pour cent elle va donc
pouvoir gagner un peu et en même temps
comme ces modèles sont très compétitifs
qualitativement et quantitativement
eh bien ils arriveront à trouver le
juste prix pour conquérir davantage de
marchés tout en reconstituant leurs
mains ce qui est évidemment très
important aussi je me dis je vous
propose qu'on jette un coup d'oeil
maintenant ensemble sur la presse et les
réactions des journaux ce matin claude
sérillon ou alors c'est pas mal mais
pourquoi vient du sitar et que feras tu
demain voilà pour résumer dans ce genre
si vous avez manqué le début des
principaux commentaires de la presse
néanmoins je garderai pour vous les
acidités pour le dessert le matin salue
une opération techniquement réussie au
père complaisamment en titre un petit
tour de force écoutez plutôt le franc
dévalué de 3% tandis que la devise
allemande et rival de 5 25% bon pour
l'emploi mauvais pour les prix françois
s'applique à mettre au clair ce que la
dévaluation va changer pour nous gabriel
farkas dans france soir est cependant
inquiets sur les chances de durer d'une
communauté dont les principaux
partenaires ne marche pas toujours une
direction
c'était inévitable cette décision
commente calmement la lettre de la
nation car charpy ne reproche pas
d'avoir dévaluer le franc par rapport au
mark mais d'avoir tant tardé à le faire
toujours ce même regret mais juin des
satisfecit un peu poli les dernières
nouvelles d'alsace à lui le grand esprit
de solidarité des allemands la
république du centre en boîte ce pas
positif fait par vous monsieur de l'or
ouest-france gouttes ce dopage mais
écrit aussi la dévaluation d'hier peut
jouer chez nous en faveur de la
croissance par l'exportation
mais cette croissance amber adam
l'inflation si quelques boulons ne sont
pas sérieusement serrer à l'intérieur
c'est maintenant que l'on va pouvoir
juger sérieusement pour la première fois
de la solidarité de la coalition
gouvernementale
suivez mon regard elysées l'humanité qui
répond en rappelant l'héritage il ne
s'agit pas de faire payer la note aux
travailleurs mais de relancer la
consommation populaire pour pour
relancer la production il faut faire
payer ceux qui ont provoqué la
dévaluation et qui compte en tirer
profit c'est sans doute pas l'idée
profonde du journal les échos mais celui
ci sans vraiment contester la décision
prise hier à bruxelles est très
catégorique il n'y a pas de dévaluation
réussissant plan d'austérité c'est le
contraire de l'endettement tous azimuts
prévues par le budget l'europe a sauvé
le franc merci ce titre le quotidien de
paris mais le franc est ébréchée ou
écornée et le quotidien énonce les
contradictions d'une dévaluation très
attendu ainsi que des victoires chaque
ticket politique monsieur françois
mitterrand en la matière sur un aparté
pour vous lire ce commentaire dominique
jamet la dévaluation traditionnellement
c'était la honte l'équivalent dans la
vie d'un dut d'un gouvernement d'une
faillite dans celle d'un commerçant de
la perte de la virginité dans celle
d'une rozière ou d'un adultère dans
celle d'un ayatollah le mot à garder
mauvaise presse alors fin de l'aparté je
reprends le parisien libéré qui qualifie
d' inévitables et urgente cette
évaluation et puis libération qui lui
avec franchise titre - huit et demi le
franc se fait tout petit devant le
marque un peu comme brassens et sa
poupée mes marques n'ont pas crié au
secours du gouvernement avait proclamé à
plusieurs reprises sa volonté de
défendre le franc il a échoué en
dévalant dit encore libération il tire
les conséquences des échecs du régime
précédent alors plus que tout petits ils
baissent pavillon écrit le figaro
c'était un revers pour le pouvoir
socialiste et ce qui est plus grave une
défaite pour la france la dévaluation le
gouvernement de la rasd imposé il la
subit et max clos dans le figaro prévoit
d'autres d'évaluation et puis carrément
écoutez plutôt la république de weimar
après la première guerre mondiale a
connu une sombre expérience analogue
elle a conduit l'allemagne à la ruine et
hitler au pouvoir c'est dans le figaro
et c'est sans nuance ah oui ils ont
bonne mine ses ministres qu'il y a
quelques jours encore affirmé qu'il
défendrait résolument le français henri
amouroux dans le journal rhône alpes qui
vous interpellent ici alors monsieur
vous avez donc eu peu ou pas du tout
dès le déloger ou je suis arrivée rue de
rivoli j'avais fait mes comptes un
réalignement au sein du système
monétaire européen et notamment
un creusement de l'écart entre le
deutsche mark et le franc était
inévitable alors pourquoi ne viens-tu
par des hôpitaux famille plutôt n'est ce
pas pas plus tard mais plutôt pourquoi
vient du sitar la formule est encore
plus jolie pourquoi vient du site heures
c'est parce que si le 23 mai
j'avais demandé que au conseil des
ministres des européens de se réunir et
de faire cette opération
dans le climat qui existait alors
tempête sur les marchés des changes dû
aux mouvements du dollar au choc qu'a
représenté le changement politique en
france
l'opération que j'aurais fait
aujourd'hui la même j'aurais dû la
recommencer deux mois plus tard et la
france la maison france aurait perdu 5%
de son pouvoir d'achat par conséquent à
cette époque alors que lui 10 ou 21 mai
on n'avait rien fait pour empêcher
l'hémorragie devise masse la seule
possibilité c'était de relever notre
garde ce que nous avons fait par la
réglementation des changes et le
relèvement des taux d'intérêt
aurait dû le faire au mois d'août
lorsque les français étant à la plage
les cambistes cultiver entre leurs
fantasmes c'est la fièvre habituel du
mois d'août
à ce moment là je n'y voyais pas clair
sur l'économie internationale et d'autre
part le marque n'était pas encore très
fort sur le marché des changes puisque
je vous rappelle la balance des
paiements de l'allemagne plus
déficitaires que celle de la france
allait-il cédé il ya quinze jours quand
il ya une toute petite poussée de fièvre
non il fallait attacher ses ceintures
c'est ce que nous avons fait il me
fallait absolument attendre les réunions
internationales de la semaine dernière à
washington pour comprendre où en est l
économie américaine les intentions du
gouvernement
rien et aussi ses positions sur les
grands problèmes mondiaux comme les
rapports nord-sud et le système
monétaire mondial en fonction de ces
considérations mes collègues européens
et moi même sommes revenus de washington
avec l'idée que les turbulences n'était
pas terminée et la ce temps s'en fout
que l'amérique que l'économie américaine
était toujours dans le brouillard que le
problème du déficit budgétaire n'était
pas réglée et que ceux ci pouvaient
entraîner une hausse des taux d'intérêt
est provisoirement un maintien du dollar
à son taux actuel dans ces conditions il
fallait renforcer le système monétaire
européen le seul moyen de le renforcer
c'était d'assainir les parités de
revenir à une certaine vérité et de
permettre au deutschemark de traduire
dans les faits la poussée potentiel nous
paraît elle n'a poussé potentiel qui
sera qui est liée à l'amélioration de
son activité économique dans les mois à
venir
féministe moi je voudrais revenir sur ce
qui risque de changer un peu dans la vie
concrète des gens en france là au delà
des relais pierre-marie peut-être avant
pris des directions plus importante
celle de la presse et celle des
syndicats et on va revenir de à votre
sujet
justement parce que ce que je voulais a
demandé à monsieur de l'heure c'est que
bon il est question de bloquer certains
prix on bloque certains prix on va
l'inflation n'est pas seulement en
fonction des prix et les fonctions des
revenus aussi est ce que est ce qu'on va
discuter un blocage des salaires aussi
d'abord je vous répète il n'ya pas
blocage général des prix en général il
ya un gel sélective des prix dont je
souhaite sortir par la conservation le
plus vite possible
l'idée centrale qui va manille mais dans
les conversations que j'aurais demain
avec les partenaires sociaux est la
suivante on peut faire mieux
à 10% de hausse des prix qu'à 14 % en
matière d'emploi car un point de gagné
sur l'inflation c'est ce sont 50000
emplois préservés et conquis on peut
faire aussi bien en matière de maintien
du pouvoir d'achat et de relèvement des
bas salaires avec une hausse des prix
des disques avec une hausse de 14 alors
pourquoi ne pas essayer la décélération
des mouvements nominaux de revenus et de
prix sécurisions ici de revenus et de
prix c'est la question que je vais me
reposer puisque les objectifs demeurent
intacts ce sont les engagements du
président la république maintien du
pouvoir d'achat en moyenne pour tout le
monde relèvement des bas revenus
notamment par la voie du salaire minimum
l'augmentation des prestations
familiales et du minimum vieillesse ceci
sera fait on peut le faire aussi bien en
ce désintoxiquant de la hausse des prix
monsieur de là ça vous intéressera
sûrement d'avoir la réaction de monsieur
roland vous connaissez bien pour la cfdt
c'est la première réaction syndicale que
nous ayons eu ce matin et vous verrez
qu'il ya effectivement une certaine
inquiétude chez les syndicats si la cfdt
en particulier
nous pensons que les travailleurs ne
doivent pas faire les frais de cette
opération mais ce qui est nécessaire
pour qu'ils fassent pas les frais de
l'opération c'est que des mesures d'une
extrême fermeté de l'entreprise une pour
que le pouvoir d'achat des bas salaires
de l' épargne populaire des prestations
sociales et familiales ne soit pas
atteint deuxièmement pour desserrer la
contrainte extérieure et en particulier
éviter des importations qui fasse monter
le coût de la vie et d'autre part je
dirais organisé mieux que par le passé
les échanges avec l'extérieur
ça ce sont des mesures qui doivent être
prises d'eau telle sorte que encore une
fois le pouvoir d'achat ne soit pas
menacée et que les prix qu'on doit
contrôler étroitement ne dérape pas oui
mais s'il ya blocage des salaires est ce
que vous êtes prêts comme en 1976 lors
du plan barre à manifester votre
désapprobation dans tout à fait il n'est
pas question qu'on accepte blocage des
salaires notamment ce qui concerne les
plus bas salaires qui encore une fois ne
doivent pas faire les frais des
opérations parcours ce qui doit être
fait encore une fois c'est une meilleure
maîtrise des prix une protection du
pouvoir d'achat et je les dis et je le
répète car c'est important une meilleure
maîtrise des échanges extérieurs pour
éviter que les prix importés ne fasse
encore dérapé le prix à la consommation
demain je vous répète ma question êtes
vous prêts à manifester commence à
s'ancrer main c'est la rançon
l'indépendance syndicale quand nous
sommes d'accord nous en disant quand
nous sommes pas d'accord nous le disons
aussi si c'est le cas si donc il ya un
plan d'austérité qui est prévue qui
touche l'ensemble des salaires nous
protesterons et nous manifesterons notre
mécontentement mais a priori je ne crois
pas que ce soit les bonnes mesures qui
qu'eric garcin qui doit être prise ce
sont d'autres mesures accompagnement
d'autres mesures d'une grande fermeté
sur le problème du prix des échanges
extérieurs et le courage dont j'ajoute à
ça une phrase tirée de l'interview que
pierre mauroy donne cet après midi au
monde le premier ministre dit les
décisions prises dimanche n'auront un
effet positif en terme de croissance et
d'emploi que si dans le même temps tous
nos compatriotes accepte de participer à
l'effort indispensable de modération des
prix et des salaires c'est la seule voie
possible pour gagner la bataille de la
reprise économique et de l'emploi alors
est-ce qu'on va pas quand même au delà
de quelques difficultés en je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec la manière dans
michel rolland a présenté les choses
il n'est pas question de faire supporter
aux travailleurs et notamment à ceux qui
sont les plus modestes il n'est pas
question de faire supporter aux
personnes âgées notamment à celles qui
ont les revenus les plus bas les
conséquences d'un réalignement monétaire
qui encore une fois aurait dû être fait
en février dernier qui était inévitable
simplement il s'agit dans la dans la
voie de la concertation et par la
politique contractuelle dont je me
rappelle quand même l'esprit puisque
c'est moi qui l'ait lancé en france il
s'agit d'aboutir à des comportements en
termes de revenus nominaux qui donne de
meilleurs résultats en termes réels et
c'est pour ça qu'avant toute orientation
j'ai décidé demain de voir le patronat
et syndicats mais je voudrais quand même
ajouter une chose
la désintoxication c'est pas simplement
la hausse des prix s'est de fait que
trop de personnes en france croit que
l'on peut vivre dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui avec de temps en temps des
dévaluations qui vous redonne un peu
artificiellement un crédit bon marché
quelles que soient les conditions
internationales c'est impensable car en
69 quand nous avons fait la dévaluation
nous avons pris un peu d'avancé sur les
autres et je vous rappelle que nous
vivions dans un système de changes fixes
que les allemands ont accepté que l'on
prenne un peu d'avancé sur eux et aussi
que la facture pétrolière et est cinq
fois inférieur à ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui donc il faut faire très
attention
or beaucoup trop de français même des
entrepreneurs sont habitués à l'idée
qu'avec une dévaluation ben ça est bien
les choses ça s'est terminé cela on fait
un réalisme remettre les pendules à
l'heure et on s'accroche et on devient
raisonnable et notre politique dans son
ensemble visera avait une convergence
avec les pays d des autres pays
européens il ya un thermomètre aussi
qu'on consulte chaque fois qu'il se
passe des choses comme ça c'est la
bourse alors là ce chef-d'oeuvre à la
bourse et on a la tendance je ne
sois santé 1 à la bourse de paris le
dollar est en hausse de 2,45 pour cent
par rapport à son cours de vendredi
autour de la corbeille les commentaires
vont bon train mais ils sont tous accès
dans une même direction les cambistes
pensent que la dévaluation est
insuffisante qu'il aurait fallu aller
plus loin et que c'est un coup d'épée
dans l'eau
sautant ou à la bourse de paris
aujourd'hui les actions des sociétés
fortement exportatrices comme les
entreprises agroalimentaires ou encore
les impuretés comme michelin ou air
liquide car rappelons le la dévaluation
pour eux est une prime à l'exportation
pour ce qui est des valeurs étrangères
par contre et c'est une indication du
marché la devise site est toujours à
7.50 ce qui montre bien sûr le marché
parisien que la dévaluation n'a pas eu
d'effet des mobilisateurs pour les
porteurs d'actions étrangères qui
s'était en quelque sorte assuré contre 7
d'évaluation sur le marché de l'or le
napoléon est en hausse de 9 ans à 900
francs mais il ya un peu des chances de
1500 pièces à peu près ont changé de
mains aujourd'hui
pour ce qui est des valeurs françaises
pour l'instant elles sont donc en légère
hausse et nous ne pensons pas que la
tendance à dire à une hausse supérieure
à 0 50%
écoutez quand on déclare
que de ré alignement est insuffisant je
sors ça revient ce que je vous dise
indiqué tout à l'heure les français sont
intoxiqués par les dévaluations et par
l'inflation je pourrais même ajouter une
chose regardez le cours du dollar il est
en hausse de 2 40% par rapport à
vendredi
si au lieu d'avoir fait -3
j'avais proposé - 6 et bien le dollar
serait en hausse de 5% par rapport à ça
et savourer ça voudrait dire deux
ennemis % de plus sur notre facture
pétrolière ce qui représenterait 4
milliards de francs à dépenser en
devises en plus voilà la réalité jours
et si j'avais demandé moins cinq ans
pour à supposer que je sois rentré dans
cette facilité si j'avais demandé - 5
mai partenaires n'auraient pas accepté
quand je suis arrivée à bruxelles hier
l'écart maximum que l'on voulait entre
deutsche mark et le franc était de 7 50
et il a fallu batailler toute une
journée pour aboutir à 8,5 en quarts
tout point accordé à la france c'est la
bataille de la compétitivité de nos
produits à l'intérieur du marché commun
qui se joue lors ceux qui disent ça
j'aimerais bien un jour qu'ils aillent à
un jeu simulé de négociations à
bruxelles y verrez ce que c'est pour
conduire la thymine prix selon m
walgreen parler parler d'inquiétude
subsiste mais je pense qu'une grande
inquiétude dans le petit mot qui est un
monde assez étroit mais quand même
important pour notre pays c'est le monde
de la création artistique il est hors de
doute qu'aujourd'hui ce pas cette place
de paris ce cette ville de paris et déjà
s'y attaquer sur le plan de l'esthétique
par des villes comme new york qui se
veulent aujourd'hui de nouvelles
florence parly cependant situation
fragile et c'est tragique est encore
augmenté partout ce qui circule comme
vous et par tout ce qu'on dit par les
hausses des taxes par le fait de la
déclaration d'une déclaration des biens
des biens par le fait que des propriétés
il ya environ 12 cents château il
constitue en france non plus des
citadelles d'un pouvoir déchu et
simplement les citadelles de beauté
touche là tout un monde créateurs je
pense aussi également aux antiquaires
qui constituent autant de vitrines de
brouter sur paris et sur la france
d'ailleurs tout ce monde qui est loin
d'être indifférent est inquiet alors
nous voudrions bien que vous enviez
partie notre inquiétude peut-être que
vous en disiez un peu plus peut-être qu
il est vrai que l'impôt sur la fortune
et d'une chose nécessaire elle est
appliquée à un peu partout simplement ce
qu'il faudrait c'est savoir ce que
voulaient au savoir si comme on vous à
l'évaluer c'est bien qu'ils sont pour
nous ils n'évaluent avoue que ça vient
quand on dit d'un objet qu'il est sans
prix s'avèrent ils sont prêts pour la
beauté mais il est également si on prie
pour les prix tout d'abord comme vous
l'avez dit vous-même cet effort de
solidarité qu'on demande à tous les
français en fonction de leur fortune et
pas simplement en fonction de leurs
revenus c'est un impôt modeste puisqu'il
rapportera nous si oui on a du mal à
faire des évaluations entre 5 et 8
milliards de francs que d'autre part
tous ceux qui rêvaient investiront dans
leurs entreprises pourront déduire de
cet impôt
ce qu'ils investissent c'est à dire ce
qu'il mêle mon maître pour la prospérité
de la france et la création d emplois en
ce qui concerne les objets d'art il
était impensable qu'il ne figure pas
dans un
dans cette assiette de 20 pouces qui
sera déclaratif d'un impôt déclaratif
chacun jugera parfois ce sera difficile
moi ça me sera difficile pour mon
logement aussi de savoir à combien je
doit l'évaluer encore que ce soit en
dessous de l'impôt sur la fortune
je vous remets mandé à maurice mais oui
bien sûr mais en pour le reste je
voudrais vous indiquer plusieurs
orientations qui devrait vous satisfaire
tout d'abord
le budget du ministère de la culture
sera portée en deux ans 1% du produit
national
il était à 0,50
laurent fabius et moi avons accepté
qu'ils passent à 0,75 il a doublé déjà
double il va doubler en deux ans
deuxièmement
le président de la république m'a dit
comment vous sentez-vous rue de rivoli
quand je lui dis c'est trop beau pour un
ministère et je pense qu'il faut ouvrir
ce magnifique salle et les oeuvres qui a
deux dents aux français et donc malgré
le l'attachement des fonctionnaires de
la rue de rivoli à leur maison ils vont
aller dans un immeuble troisièmement cet
immeuble il faudra qu'il soit beau c'est
à dire que comme à new york
eh bien nous fassions aso pour avoir
même des immeubles où on travaille il
soin de poser ma non j'en ai bien viandé
d'homme ça existe aussi en france qui
est alors elle à la création voilà et en
plus donc c'est un appel à la création
et le ministre de la culture se
déploiera tous azimuts et recevra toutes
les professions qui sont intéressés à ça
et on verra je crois les aspects très
positifs
dans le domaine de la sculpture du
cinéma de la peinture de la musique et
bien monsieur de l'or nous vous
remercions de nous avoir prêté 10 dans
le moule vert bien d'autres choses à
faire en ce moment et on va revenir aux
but 7
cette émission consacrée à mes demandes
et s'en va en rester là pour ce qui est
de la dévaluation qui était évidemment
le sujet du jour gérard les autres
nouvelles de la journée oui il faut
quand même ajouter que jacques chirac
sera cet après midi une déclaration
importante au cours d'une conférence de
presse qui constituera sa rentrée bien
au franc d'uche ses analyses et ses
commentaires sur la dévaluation et
demain valéry giscard d'estaing travers
lui la parole pour la première fois
depuis le 10 mai pour justement donner
ses commentaires sur ce que cette
dévaluation qui a été annoncé hier soir
en dehors de ce dossier économique
important le second événement je ne sais
le débat sur l'énergie qui doit avoir
lieu à partir de demain à l'assemblée
nationale nous y reviendrons largement
puisque notre invité sera demain jean
pierre chevènement le ministre de la
recherche scientifique et de la
technologie
ce débat vous le savez déjà depuis
longtemps ouvert dans l'opinion durant
le week-end plusieurs manifestations ont
eu lieu à paris mais aussi sur le site
de la future centrale de golfech la la
violence s'est ajoutée à la conviction
des antinucléaires la plupart des
installations provisoires d'edf ont été
détruites et des affrontements se sont
produits avec les forces de l'ordre il
ya eu une trentaine de blessés légers
aujourd'hui ce sont les pro nucléaires
qui veulent faire entendre leur voix de
manifestations sont prévues à cherbourg
et à l' usine de retraitement de la
hague ce débat sur l'énergie donc prévu
pour durer deux jours il divise le monde
politique tant dans l'opposition que
dans la majorité alors pour essayer de
poser les problèmes nous avons invité au
crible georges besse qui est responsable
de la cogema il a en charge la gestion
du combustible nucléaire en france au
sein du commissariat à l'énergie
atomique il répond aux questions de
philippe dumas oui que vous vous sentez
vous ce débat sur l'énergie vous qui
êtes un promoteur justement de l'énergie
nucléaire en france on veut nous ne
ressentons avec sérénité nous avons
toujours considéré nous considérons que
le développement l'énergie nucléaire en
france et les programmes dépendent du
gouvernement et par voie de conséquence
du parlement vous pensez pas que ce soit
une mauvaise chose de supprimer
certaines proches de réacteurs
nucléaires aux fausses une évidente que
je suis pro nucléaire bien sûr
je pense néanmoins que ce qui a été
décidé par le gouvernement
correspond bien un maintien des
objectifs qui étaient prévus ont pas
souri le desserrement de l'étreinte
pétrolières qui pèsent actuellement sur
le pétrole et sur l'ensemble de
l'approvisionnement énergétique français
échappent réserve bien quand même
l'avenir parce qu'il faut savoir combien
consomme moins d'électricité en 1990
chez c'est toujours bien l'ex ils à
prévoir un de vos domaines c'est
justement leur traitement lusine de lag
ce n'est pas une technique est très au
point est ce que cette usine ne marche
pas au mieux de ses possibilités
alors vous justement vous voulez encore
la développer c'est pas prendre un
risque au boom économique
vous posez une question
un peu brutal cette usine fonctionne
bien il ne faut pas toujours croire
quand même les gens qui critiquent cette
usine a été construite et a démarré en
1976 dont les capacités de production
que vous avez actuellement sont
nettement inférieures à celles que vous
aviez prévu en pas exactement la
capacité de cette usine à environ 2 250
à 300 tonnes inférieur à la capacité
nominale qui était prévu pour un
combustible
type simule combustible d'edf en fait
nous retraitons toute une série de
conditions de provenances diverses
d'europe et deux réacteurs différentes
par conséquent ça diminue un type et la
capacité actuellement une usine de la
hague traite en même temps ou plutôt ces
périodes différentes des combustibles
gaz graphite et les combustibles aux
légères par conséquent actuellement elle
ne fonctionne sur le jir que à peu près
un mois tu t'entends même un peu moins
mais fonctionne pas mal dans la mesure
où le débat sur l'énergie concerne
finalement pas mal de problèmes
économiques dans quelle mesure où
l'énergie nucléaire offre pas mal
dallaire comment pouvez-vous déterminé
que le prix de l'énergie nucléaire est
moins cher que d'autres produits vous
poser une question qui va un petit peu
en dehors de mes compétences puisque la
cogema comme vous le savez traite le
cycle du combustible nucléaire et non
pas les centrales de puissance les
centrales de puissance ou celui qu'il y
en à peu près une vingtaine qui sont
actuellement en fonctionnement et qui
fonctionne bien même mieux que ce qui
était prévu puisque leur rendement est
de l'ordre de 70% n'est ce pas un
facteur de charge donc de ce côté là il
n'y a pas de surprise on peut établir
les prix d'une manière correcte dans le
reste du 6 était leur production
d'uranium 'sans riche dense mais ça ça
nous concerne et nous connaissons bien
lé prix de revient et ils sont
parfaitement établis dans le domaine du
retraitement nous maîtrisons leur
traitement d'une manière suffisante pour
fixer les prix parce que maintenant on
est polarisée actuellement sur leur
traitement d'eau légère mais vous savez
nous faisons du retraitement depuis 25
ans
l'ensemble cea d'abord et cogema ensuite
nous avons retraités plus de dix mille
tonnes de combustible irradié depuis
1958 c'est donc une technique que nous
procédons bien
à l'étranger voilà le temps que la
lumière revienne il faut retenir aux
etats unis une photo de famille qu'on
aurait peu de chance de voir en france
en inde reagan en effet réuni autour de
lui pour mettre tous les atouts dans son
jeu dans la sphère des avions awacs et
pour convaincre hall sénat réticent a
donc réuni de décider de réunir autour
de lui les différents conseillers des
six présidents américains précédents il
s'agit pour un adrian de tenter de dun
démontré que la plupart des spécialistes
de ces six générations de ministres
soutiennent son projet de vente d'avions
espions à l'arabie saoudite parmi les
plus connus de ces personnalités
kissinger breathe in ski et d'autres non
et déjà beaucoup plus anciens le prix du
paquet de cigarette provoque un nouvel
affrontement en pologne entre solidarité
et le gouvernement la hausse de 100% du
prix du tabac justifié hier à gdansk le
déplacement de deux ministres deux
ministres venus s'expliquer sur les
raisons de cette augmentation
devant le refus de revenir sur cette
décision lech walesa dans une ambiance
survoltée adulé congédié de la tribune
du congrès de solidarité dans de
nombreuses régions de pologne on brandit
déjà la menace d'une grève pour
protester contre cette hausse en tout
cas il faut savoir que dorénavant le
prix d'un paquet de cigarettes
correspond à environ une heure de
travail effectif par rapport au salaire
moyen d'un ouvrier pologne en france le
week end sportif a été l'occasion d'une
révélation corinne ragazzacci une jeune
fille de 12 ans s'est largement imposée
aux championnats de france de
gymnastique qui avait lieu à nantes
corinne le ragga tati est d'ailleurs en
direct avec nous dans le studio de
marseille merci d'être venu pierre fut
là vous avez assisté à ces championnats
et en quoi la performance de corinne
riga safieh est remarquable eh bien
d'abord on peut lui poser tout de suite
la question à 12 ans comment
ressent-elle tout à coup c'est
projecteurs de l'actualité ils sont
dirigés sur son joli visage corinne vous
m'entendez
alors comment vous ressentez toutacoo
d'apparaître sur les écrans de
télévision alors que vous connaissez pas
il ya 48 heures c'est la première fois
et 500 partants ça a été difficile de
battre les vieilles de 17 ans
déchirer les éléments couple
et puis on va voir pierre les images des
exhibitions de corinne yven commenté
nous situer le lot difficulté points
exactement alors voilà corinne je vous
invite à vous de découvrir peut-être
pour la première fois au plus haut
niveau national au sol les tapas ruffine
souples légères gracieuse une expression
corporelle qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celle des petites roumaine et des
petites soviétique une présence en tout
cas qui n'a pas laissé insensible les
juges ni les observateurs que nous
sommes incontestablement corinne
ragazzacci 12 ans 1 m 40 8 pour 31 kg
nous ne sont pas sûrs du poids exact
mais corinne ma nous le dire la voici
lors des saltos des sceaux demain et des
sauts périlleux
c'est vrai qu'elle a exécuté au sol des
figures de très grande valeur mondiale
elle est de la trempe des grandes stars
de la gymnastique mais à 12 ans on ne
peut encore se prononcer car tout
dépendra de sa progression jusqu'à 15 en
effet corinne à gaza qui ne pourra
participer ou vous avez un petit goyer
une petite faute d'appréciation ici lors
de sa réception mais c'est bien dans
l'ensemble
je disais que elle ne pourra participer
aux jeux olympiques de los angelès à 15
ans revoici regardez bien lors d'un
double saut périlleux
c'est une difficulté mondial est allé
paraît ici par l'entraîneur chinois qui
a été
envoyée justement un marseille au centre
national de sage signé où elle a été
découverte par daniel félicie mais on
pourrait peut-être lui demandait comment
à 12 ans on peut concilier les exigences
d'un entraînement à ce niveau et une vie
de jeune fille corinne cau bientôt
quatre nuits par jour alors vous avez un
aménagement d'horaires je crois pas aux
études parce qu'il faut vous situer sur
le plan scolaire vous êtes en quatrième
secondaire 1 oui je vais à l'école de 8h
à 12h et l'après midi je recommençais de
sartre à faire alors la question
important de corinne eux c'est de savoir
à 15 ans combien vous mesurerez commun
vous poserez parce que pour l'instant
vous êtes une petite poupée est
magnifique mais est ce que n'avait pas
peur de grossir de grandir est ce que ce
manque beaucoup de sacrifices maintenant
bah oui j'ai un peu peur mais je fasse
attention jusqu'à 15 ans puis après sur
l'océan est ce que votre moment vous
prépare des petits plats vous vivez au
régime ben oui c'est moi qui décide un
peu mais elle elle m'aide pour la
nourriture l'école est alors plus de
sucreries plus de loisirs des jeunes
filles de votre âge ou à osaka la
gymnastique ah non j'ai fait comme les
gentils des normales
j'ai des loisirs comme les autres je
vais inscrire à la neige partout et si
vous grossissez de 5 kg par exemple ça
va tout changer dans votre silhouette
bah oui on tenait
je ferai le régime pendant quelques
jours qu'ils savaient que nadia comaneci
peut exactement le même poids et mesurer
à m 48 aux jeux de montréal elle avait
déjà beaucoup d'avant sur vous est-ce
que vous aspirez dell ou des soviétiques
j'inspire l'aider parce qu'ils sentent
toutes les vidéos si van persie
corinne j'espère qu'on verra dans
d'autres l'exhibition c'est pas ça
s'appelle des exhibitions si c'est vous
c'est le terme exact sur ces deux là par
ce monsieur
non sur les trous mais sous le soulève
souvent la main de gaoussou la main de
lautrec est alors revenir à votre livre
maurice race les collectionneurs publié
chez ramsay vous l'avais appelé les
collectionneurs mais vous distinguer en
fait trois catégories les
collectionneurs les amateurs et les
curieux alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire une distinction je veux je
crois qu'il était honteux pas la faire
la distinction c'est à dire que un
curieux n'est pas nécessairement un
collectionneur un collectionneur ou en
général est un homme curieux je pense
que la meilleure façon d'être c'est ce
mode amateurs
ne pas être dans cet amour des objets
est propulsé par le profit propulsé par
l'orgueil propulsé par le snobisme qui
arrive si souvent est ce ce que j'écris
un peu dans mon livre c'est à dire cette
description tous ces éléments qui
constituent au fond la collection mais
non on va avoir quelques portraits tout
à l'heure je vais vous demander de nous
rappeler qu'ils sont dans votre livre
mais d'abord on va peut-être faire un
tour à la salle des ventes puisque c'est
un peu le temps plein vous en parlait
d'ailleurs comme d'une église et comme
d'un cul l'immeuble est un os par edith
célébration on a aussi un véritable
culte ouais alors on va on va faire un
tour la salle des ventes aujourd'hui
débute à 8
un joli ça rock anciens du début du
siècle de mettre deux sur un même temps
le marché des ventes aux enchères semble
ne pas mal se porter d'une manière
générale dans les salles et en
particulier à l'hôtel drouot le temple
du bout comme l'appellent les
commissaires priseurs
ville par monsieur 2000 oui malgré le
contexte difficile il n'y aurait pas
d'augmentation du nombre des ventes dit
forcé de liquidation par exemple donc la
crise mais pas encore ressenti de ce
côté les pièces rares comme ans si l'on
ose dire à se faire rares
le cycle est toujours en vigueur mais
dans les familles les objets sont
maintenant vendues tous les 25 ans en
moyenne enfin les amateurs modeste
constituent 90 % de la clientèle et la
majorité des objets sont abordables
quant à l'achat il se fait surtout au
coup de coeur
savoir exactement quels sont les niveaux
de toute notre clientèle et je crois
qu'en particulier on a beaucoup de 2,2
de gens qui ne sont pas automatiquement
des professionnels mais des particuliers
qui viennent ici à la fois pour
distraire et puis pour acheter un objet
qui leur fait plaisir vous croyez qu'il
cherche quelque chose à placer les
équipes cherchent la spéculation qui
cherchent uniquement pour la décoration
mais je crois pas que les gens quand ils
viennent ici cherche prescrit culation
je crois qu'avant tout le le particulier
quand il vient l'hôtel cherche surtout
lé l'objet l'objet qui les fait plaisir
qui lui plaît qui pense va égayer son
intérieur on achète un objet pas
uniquement pour faire de spéculations et
vous estimez madame que vous représentez
un peu d'appui en attaque classique
l'hôtel drouot des salles de ventes en
général
oui je pense c'est à dire des gens qui
viennent un peu par hasard et qui
regarde qui tombe sur un objet qui leur
plaît son trait
même faire un des sacrifices ans le fait
le marché international se porte bien
car les incertitudes monétaires ont
toujours été favorables aux
investissements en valeur refuge et en
français ce qu'il y a une conséquence en
quelque sorte des mouvements politiques
économiques sociaux depuis 10 mai par
exemple eh bien je crois qu'en france
il n'y a pas d'effet de conjoncture et
que au fond
les comportements sont beaucoup plus des
comportements passionnel il ya d'abord
la mode
par exemple
le goût du rétro
1925 1900 et la clientèle comment se
comporte hôtel est ce qu'il ya un
renouvellement je crois je crois que la
clientèle n'a que tendance à s'élargir
et dans tous les niveaux et dans toutes
les couches sociales on vient petit à
petit au goût de l'objet d'art et ça
pour nous c'est très satisfaisant et
dans quel esprit achète un client est ce
que c'est le coup de foudre je crois que
c'est un phénomène de coups de coeur
le l'amateur se pose trois questions
est-ce que l'objet me plaît ce que je
l'aisne
deuxièmement est-ce que je peux me le
payer
puis troisièmement il faut le
reconnaître est ce que je fais un bon
investissement la loi en principe
devrait obliger bientôt les acheteurs à
payer avec un chèque au delà de 5000
alors y aura-t-il un frein aux
transactions eh bien il ya un projet
effectivement d'obliger le paiement par
chèque au delà de 5000 francs
je pense que cette idée destinée à
lutter contre la fraude fiscale ce qui
est juste
risque
d'être inefficace est aussi pénalisante
pour les professionnels inefficace parce
que ces transactions elles auront lieu
elles auront lieu clandestinement et
pénalisant parce que les professionnels
compétents
qui croient en leurs professions qui ont
investi pour la développer pour faire de
paris un grand marché de l'art risque de
voir beaucoup d'affaires leur échapper
l'amateur peut se faire plaisir avec un
achat à 300 francs seulement parce que
l'objet choisi un passé c'est cette âme
qui explique le succès grandissant des
enchères ou le courant passe entre le
client la pièce vendue et le commissaire
priseur qui est un arbitre sachant faire
revivre l'objet
effet en ville pressants
voilà c'était un partage gérard dalmas
la salle des ventes donc sanerot samedi
votre confrère monsieur adhère parle de
comportements passionnel m reims où il
oeuvrait au portemanteau je suis les
courses en lisant votre fille valentine
s'attache à n'importe quoi là où joue
l'un des petit décroissant oui je pense
que tout objet est en lui même une chose
qu'on peut collectionner c'est pour ça
que très souvent il faut vous pouvez un
jour pour entreprendre une collection
pour lui tout je crois que il suffit
simplement d'avoir un peu d'originalité
désagréments raconte une anecdote celle
de ce fonctionnaire qui était était
amoureuse louis saez au point de s'être
procuré cinq mieux si j'ai j'ai retrouvé
cette anecdote
en un jour dans les détours delà du
vieux de la vieille préfecture de police
où il ya un musée je ne sais pas s'il
existe toujours amusé des des armes
amuser de tout ce qu'on avait pu saisir
isabey saisine guillotine dont on
prétendait qu'elle avait été une des
guillotines révolutionnaire y en a
quatre ou cinq qui reste comme ça dans
les collections est un des
hommes a passionné amoureux de celle de
la première évolutionnaire de louis saez
et de marie-antoinette tous les 21
janvier célébrer l'anniversaire du
sacrifice royal en mettant sa tête dans
une guillotine de ces guillotine qui
l'avait acheté qui avait fait monter
chez lui l'avait obligé à prendre un
appartement au plafond pour pouvoir la
mettre et tous les 21 janvier ils
jouaient ce simulacre ce simulacre de
l'exécution du roi mettant sa tête et un
jour d'un 21 janvier à 22 janvier au
matin les locataires du chou au vu des
traces rouges
sur le plafond et je raconte que
l'horreur que qu'éprouve al commissaire
de police et ceux qui l'accompagnaient à
retrouver l'homme qui s'était lui-même
décapité ce qui était du même décapité
parce qu'ils avaient assez de devis en
c'était super de tragédies royal ou bien
une erreur de fonctionnement global jean
paul s'il ya d'autres histoires comme
celle là et qui nous montre jusqu'où
peut aller la passion vrai que vous nous
parlez aussi de cet amateur de la
fontaine oui j'en ai plus d'amateurs de
la fontaine mais y en a bien d'autres
comme ça de passion j'ai connu j'ai
connu par exemple une dame qui se
prenait une dame qui collectionnait les
shows les les porcelaines de saxe
et qui s'était pris elle même à la fin
de sa vie pour une personne de supporter
seule elle même forcé naufragés ce qui
fait qu'elle n'osait plus s'asseoir de
peur de se détruire elle même bien
mettre reims malheureusement nous ne
pouvons pas aller au delà et le temps
qui nous est imparti est achevée alors
je rappelle le titre de votre livre les
collectionneurs je vous invite fortement
à le lire parce qu'il est bourré
d'histoire comme ça de réflexion sur le
marché de l'art et sur l'objet c'est
passionnant il ya aussi de belles
photographies merci m reims merci à vous
tous prochains rendez vous de
l'information 18h30 c'est la vie